on est parti là égalitairement parce que
je pense que tout le monde mérite
d'avoir la même portion était pas
poisson au niveau rottu mange de la
viande maintenant je suis pesko times
j'ai pas mangé de viande depuis six ans
les gardes de viande rouge les bonobos
portent et la
foi si c'est moi qui décide et j'aurais
mis aux plus grosses portions garçons et
puis des petites portions office c'est
assez clair et net parce qu'on a besoin
d'énergie aussi pour pour carburer etc
alors est ce que vous êtes choqués par
les propos de vos visites ont été
énormément relayé non géré a dit non je
suis pas choqué parce que voilà il est
en train de crever la dalle et il se dit
franchement face est pas une un truc
très réfléchie pour dire les garçons ils
ont plus besoin d'un an d'abord de toute
façon de façon biologique c'est vrai que
quand on met d'un homme au régime quand
on met une femme au régime on les met
pas au même niveau de galeries calorique
et puis je pense pas qu'il y avait qu il
y avait une pensée sexiste pour dire les
filles sont plus faibles et donc ceci ou
cela il l'a dit comme ça parce qu'ils
avaient faim sur le moment mais sont
dans des conditions extrêmes et si c'est
à dire que moi si tu me donnes pas à
bouffer pendant trois semaines que j'ai
pas le droit mon petit steaks hachés
c'est vrai que je peux vite dire des
choses ou pas être impulsif c'est l'art
c'est une sorte d'impulsivité qui n'est
pas maîtrisée mais je pense pas qu'il
soit fondamentalement misogyne pour y
rester sur un poteau
wenn man palais sur un poteau et
dégoûtant respecter
oui ce que disent ou go et valérie est
scandaleux et cet homme là on réduite je
suis très en colère contre la production
s'est il aura dû être coupée cet homme
est passible d'une condamnation au
tribunal en mai la formation dif 1 mais
écoutez moi même jour à l'horizon ne
vous laissez pas comme si départ il
me dire des conneries plainte en
diffamation pour sexisme non passibles
d'une contravention de 750 euros s'est
passé ont tout ce qu'il a dit les hommes
doivent manger plus que les feux des
coûts et s'est
jamais choisi est mon idole alors déjà
le sexisme pour toi or de quoi on n'en
peut plus et en plus c'est un jeu de
survie c'est pas un show d'élégance et
koh lanta c'est pas un bachelor donc en
fait moi je trouve qu'il a raison en
plus l'om s10 2500 kcal pour les hommes
et de 1000 calories par les femmes dont
on n'a pas besoin du même nom de
calories quand on est une femme et un
homme il veut juste s'en sortir et moi
je trouve que c'est très bien il la
politiquement correct et voilà il a dit
sont sans aucun sexisme c'est plutôt
sympa en fait c'est ceux qui l'accusent
de sexisme qui sont sexistes a mis tout
le monde lui tombe dessus parce que
c'est un homme candidats de koh lanta
demain si c'est un nutritionniste ou une
famille tri sony ce qui va vous
l'expliquer tout le monde va faire
personne n'a rien dit si ç'avait été une
femme kate qui avait dit sa personne n'a
rien dit donc en fait il est victime de
sexisme à verser exactement et deux
hélicoptères du tout tu t'ennuies et tu
tweets en regardant cette émission parce
que franchement c'était très ennuyeux
hier soir et pas dire je me rendais sur
vous il a dit
oui mais on avait écouté sa possible
mais ce qu'elle va dire c'est que y'a
tellement rien et c'est tellement rien
passé cherche c'est très petites choses
à on a cherché
cherché la bâtisse et des
tchadiens non parce que oui ça dans la
gorge pardon non mais c'est sérieux
c'est au fond on est quand même dans la
survie donc ces mêmes de la galerie
choquer ou pas mais oui choqué bâtiment
je suis choqué on est
on est dans un jeu de survie ils ont pas
mangées tu sais pas combien hubbard et
permet aux mamans sa portion femme sur
cinq ans jusqu'à jian ont choisi il veut
gagner arrivé chez choquer ou pas
été choqué j'ai pu accéder à galanterie
pas forcément moi je suis choqué c'est
pire que du ccid du sexisme c'est même
presque est ce que tu es choqué oui
[Rires]
j'arrête tout de mes tweets oui j'ai dit
c'est même de croire que du sexisme ces
deux c'est carrément un manque de
galanterie devrait donner sa part m
enfin non plus entre je suis dit voilà
c'est bien là tu vois
ses bas ses démons coûte